the five actors who are accredited in
here three of them are white but the
other one the main act the top-billed
actresses Oprah Winfrey is black and
they got Mindy Kaling who's was an
Indian and I think she's Indian we don't
if we wrong about that we're not being
racist okay we're just trying to say
like a school should have everybody yay
ever tried today
what's going on guys Greg Alva here John
Humphrey warning you I have hiccups
right now I don't know if I can stop
just hiccuping but I'm going to focus on
them the sooner they're going to go away
anywhere we just watch the wrinkle in
time official trailers yeah and boy oh
boy that trailer was quite heavy and
dark sweet dreams are made of these
playing over the images cristyne looking
depressed I believe this is his
follow-up role as his follow Steve
Trevor performance yes Steve Terrell
applied through like a you know a fold
in spam and comes out on the opposite
side on his whole other planning he's
trapped you know he created the
tesseract it's crazy yeah I feel like
Steve Trevor's performances because well
he's charismatic in Wonder Woman he's
like super charismatic in Star Trek he
tones down the charisma stuff in Wonder
Woman is a little more serious and now
he's just really serious that's our
first time is going to be one of those
actors is always smiling oh he is super
ridiculously charming but it seems like
he's embodying much more mature roles
ever since like hell or high water
Wonder Woman and now this man he's not
just some young man anymore he's a fully
grown adult with a beard and everything
well I think this is a cool project for
him to do not only because of who's
involved which is you know given its
status and literary history because it
is a pretty notable book and it is
reasonably beloved it won many awards so
this is a high-profile project I'm
surprised this movie hasn't this book
hasn't been adapted more times actually
I've never read the book and I've never
seen any of like the TV at fhd done the
one TV adaptation is they've been
several they've done one different
several from wrinkle in time where's the
second most adapted adaptation of any
book next to the New Testament of the
Jesus Christ sewers there might be more
wrinkle and time adaptations yeah then
all those toys man yeah comic book
spin-offs oh yeah now the whole book
universe building here but if you were
actually read the book so much go into a
little more detail of what you saw yeah
I mean I read the book when I was
younger like admittedly but I did read
it all the way through I did a book
report on it and did you pass I think so
I don't like it I tried to convince a
lot of people to read this book and
everybody every time I did that I must
not have explained it very well because
everybody just told me it sounded dumb
but it is kind of a hard book to
describe and it's kind of a hard movie
to get across in this teaser trailer so
I'm not like losing my mind about it but
it did make me curious it is one of
those I know a lot of people compare
Madeleine Ling Dale's work to like CS
Lewis in the way that like Narnia is
sort of borrows a lot from Christian
mythology and things like that and a
wrinkle in time has a lot of those big
overarching like light versus darkness
metaphors but it is also sci-fi does a
lot of interplanetary you know
space-time travel the three women you
know miss what did miss which M is who
they have these sort of powers of sorta
that unfold over time I also don't want
to give away the story the book but they
are imbued with something magical it's
pretty apparent in this trailer you know
the trailer gives you a lot of images so
it seems like it's showing you what the
different worlds will look like that
makes me excited like they look cool I'm
certainly happy that Ava Duvernay is
getting to do this kind of thing - yeah
she seems like she's made a lot of
important stuff you know she's made some
documentary she's made she made Selma
which is like pretty big important film
that got kind of snubbed at the time and
it came out you know it's kind of cool
to see what she's doing in this corner -
you know branching out into the big
blockbuster range
I guess Chris Pines becoming that male
leading actor for female directors that
hop from dramatic much smaller film to
huge blockbuster studio yeah yeah that's
weak that's it Chris Pine is to fill
these shoes for these female directors
and grant attract the concept of a
tesseract a tesseract is a real
geometric concept the easiest way to
describe is like what a cube is to a
square that's what a tesseract is to a
cube God looks like an even QB or cube
and it's sort of like a fifth
dimensional shape so to speak and that's
where the sci-fi comes into this is a
whole bunch of stuff about that because
their parents are scientists what I feel
from someone who hasn't read the book
and this is really my first glimpse at
what the hell-- wrinkle in time is I
know wrinkle times when a book it's been
around for a long time this does look
like a Disney movie it does like
specifically not I'm not talking about
how
but in terms of visual imagery in style
you know you didn't buy what Alice in
Wonderland or any Alice live-action
Disney adaptations that we've been
getting over the years it does have a
similar type of production design and
qualitative look to it I really am
getting the impression that the tone of
it will probably be a lot lighter than
what the actual teaser trailer is is
conveying here I'm sure there will be
dark elements I mean there's a lot of
shots of Chris Pine looking rather
depressed the kids look like there's
serious heavy situations yeah I feel
like it gets heavier as it goes along is
he like imprisoned on some other planet
okay yeah his Oprah the bad guy no she's
I would guess she's miss whatsit I think
in the book she's like a neighbor of
theirs who comes over one day like all
these kids live with their mom together
and the story is mainly about the
daughter and her little brother who's
kind of a genius a little bit and who
can sort of read mine and they meet Miss
whatsit at some point she like comes by
their house or whatever and I and that's
where the adventure spiral is off so the
main three characters are and I'm
blanking on the names exactly are the
girl Charles Wallace little brother and
then the girl's friend okay you know
it's kind of also an outcast at school
and there's a lot of that I remember the
book there's a lot of that whimsy at
first and then as the stakes get higher
and the kids gotta learn adult lessons
and learn that your parents don't always
have the answers and that you know
there's some things you got fixed on
your own things get darker I guess what
I'm really rooting for for this movie
it's surprisingly rare when these
classic fantasy novels get adapted into
the big screen and fly by well with most
of mainstream audience you know like
lore the way Harry Potter did it really
well yeah they managed to satisfy both
market yeah they have a Chronicles of
Narnia seem to keep dipping in quality
Alice in Wonderland was just a giant
visual feast and then I think that this
even though the first one made a billion
dollars I think there was still a
disappointment factor that played into
Alice Through the Looking Glass ensuring
that those bugs that movie failed at the
box office and I think with this one the
visuals yeah they look absolutely
amazing and it's like I expect nothing
less of a major studio like Disney to
provide that but you know for an average
audience movie go
like me who hasn't read the book I
probably might enjoy it but I know for
book fans they're really gonna want a
great story and for that to be honored
with its characters not they're not
going to be as hung up on like the
visual feast and all yeah and even as an
average audience movie goer I can get
bored of that and I would care much more
about the actual characters in the
actual story lines that are happening in
so that's just my one like minor concern
only because of previous films that have
been adapted before and this is Disney
who did Alice in Wonderland
you know I'm curious about this movie in
particular because Alice in Wonderland
is much more of an industry you know
like there's the animated movie it's
more ubiquitous across culture you know
there are toys and other things and
they're even video games that are based
on Alice one oh I don't know how they're
gonna pull this off cause the thing I
don't get from this trailer is like
there are creatures and stuff in this
story like it gets pretty fantasy at
least at certain points well that last
scene really had a black mayor vibe to
me yeah yeah major black mare and you
know I feel like this will be a
balancing act and I hope you know it's
like they bothered to get Ava Duvernay
to make this you know so I hope that
this is just as concerned with its story
as its candy-colored visual because you
kind of have to do both you know it is
sort of a broad sci-fi fantasy but it is
also very much about its mean stuff so
um yeah that's that's the stuff that I
don't quite know about from this trailer
but nothing in this yet
raises any red flags for me I guess I'm
excited that Oprah's back yeah you know
I don't know if Oprah's index I haven't
heard over being back I feel like she
acts once in a while when the right
situation come to him who this is easily
since she ended her show yeah this is
easily the biggest film she's in where
she's really in the trailer
please hear she's talking and you're
like oh it was a predominant character
in this trailer and I think that's
really exciting she's a really talented
actress yeah the director of this she's
a black director too right that's really
cool it's a nice victory Ninh uh yeah
women and people with color you like it
and and I'm excited for them you know I
like I'll admit like I hope that this
goes well for that sake just because you
know there's an unfair uh skew when you
know such if something like this doesn't
do
you know yeah like given all the things
that are involved in some of the more
progressive changes they have made with
it not that I think it really specifies
what race everybody is in the book I've
never sung about it when I was a kid
anyway I definitely hope that they can
nail this with some poise there seems to
be a lot and understandably so some
people might not find it a big deal they
don't get what the big deal is about
when you hear about like female
directors directing a huge studio film
the core of this story is pretty
feminine like that a lot of the main
characters are Phoenix I respect the
fact that they're getting female
directors in the studio's now to do
these shoot much bigger movies yeah
because some people might not think
that's a big deal but it is because
portal there's a reason why when patty
Jing is it wonderful I've I've huge heel
because it's usually male directors who
do the big Hollywood films you know and
even like what the Disney movies it's
like Jon Favreau Tim Burton Kenneth
Branagh they're all like male directors
or if I do it like so just I like their
talents and wedges
it's nice especially right now that it's
you know that much more important not
the norm like it is definitely a good
thing I love that true these movies that
are about kids it's like or even Alice
in Wonderland yeah I think the main
actress was and actually 15 I think
she's an adult that is a matter yeah
well good Wonderland is no one really
cared to know who that actress was your
day you know nebulas 18 to 20 you know a
Prague of Narnia everyone's like weird
musical life yeah and in here and like I
remember the brief kind of seeing I know
about wrinkle time is that the main
characters are the kids yeah and did not
even credited on the trailer I know I
think and I get it like you know we know
these other names better but today I
mean yeah the heart of the story yeah
it's kind of fascinating to me and also
the writer this
Jennifer Lee Jennifer Lee she wrote
wreck-it Ralph she worked on the story
for Zootopia she wrote frozen which is
you know a lot of people love that movie
I personally don't let it just a lot of
people think that's like an amazing film
it's cool that the behind the scenes
people are females and you said yourself
there's a lot of feminine qualities to a
wrinkle and time yet so I'm excited that
I like working on the big like big
female production
yeah yeah then I'm nothing with leaves
yeah and I'm excited for that for that
and to me now I'm just wondering how
much the other side of this is going to
play just the big expensive fantasy
movie part is going to get into that
because you know I don't know how
they're approaching this because the
novel wasn't like wildly successful when
it came out so I don't know lassic it is
yeah yeah it's definitely regarded to be
a classic but it's not the never a young
adult mouth right now and so I guess
just as a person who pays attention to
the movie industry
I don't know from this trailer if
they're going to try and make this some
kind of why a flagship or if they're
just gonna do this story you know and
that's something that I always got to be
a little curious about just because it
would be easy for this to fall into that
I think it should I think any chance you
get to make a franchise and do it yes
every time every time set up sequels
post-credit scenes announcements before
the movie is out that's what I like for
every single film my man watch there
which is one movie I know right well why
would I invest my time is something
that's going to end yeah whoa guys
thanks for tuning in you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and check out our
exclusive perks and rewards over at
patriotic ups.com flash the real rejects
would love to have you there yeah ma